hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
book one of augustine's confessions
after narrating his infancy and his
acquisition of language he then tells us
about his education the years that he
spends going to school
in some respects augustine is quite
fortunate that his parents can afford to
send him to school on the other hand his
school experiences are
in large part quite negative and we
could say that there's a lot of mistaken
priorities going into
not just how students are educated but
what they're actually
learning and the adults are
you know largely to blame
for that so this begins in chapter nine
and he says that um
it was impressed upon me that to behave
properly as a boy i must obey my
teachers
why this was all that i might succeed in
the world and excel in those arts of
speech which would serve to bring honor
among men and to gain deceitful riches
hence i was sent to school to acquire
learning the utility of which wretched
child that i was i did not know so the
adults are giving augustine this
consistent message hey the way to a good
life is through education and so you've
got to go to school to acquire
learning now it's it's you know very
interesting if you think about this
kids really never know
why the hell they're supposed to be
there
what this learning is until they've
actually acquired it and maybe some of
them never do or maybe the teachers are
bad and they you know maybe they acquire
miseducation that then has to be
corrected later on or never does get
corrected so it's impressed upon him a
couple basic
principles you might say you need to
obey your teachers and you can ask well
why do i need to obey my teachers well
the answer is because they're your
teachers and their authorities and
they're the ones who know better than
you right and then what is he supposed
to be seeking
success
honor riches this is a very
instrumentalized understanding
of education but and one that we see
many people
uh articulating today right they're
captivated by this notion that education
is going to make you healthy and wealthy
and wise right the art of speech that
he's supposed to be studying augustine
will in fact go on to become a
rhetorician and to teach rhetoric
it's supposed to give him access to
these things so in a in a way instead of
like concentrating
on the studies for their own sake
he's supposed to do that so that he can
you know be a success in life
and this is what his parents want and
this is what other adults are telling
him he needs to do
now one of the key aspects of pedagogy
at the time is corporal punishment
beating
beating students
he says that
if i was slow at learning i was beaten
and he talks about this in a number of
places in the
coming chapters
does this actually help people to learn
no as a matter of fact we we know that
this is often
counterproductive but the idea is that
you induce fear
and that that fear will make the person
concentrate on their studies because
they don't want to incur the punishment
and the adults view this as a good
method this is great pedagogy and
they're themselves saying well this is
what happened to me back when i was
young so obviously i turned out okay it
must be good for you
as well and we could probably say that
about these sadistic teachers that he
runs into
as well he says this method was praised
by our forebearers many of whom had
passed through this life before us and
laid out the hard paths we were forced
to follow
and this leads augustine to his first
prayers he says we discovered certain
men prayed to you and he learned from
them and imagined you as far as we could
as some sort of mighty one who could
hear us and help us even though not
appearing before our senses
while still a boy i began to pray to you
my help and my refuge and then praying
to you i broke the knots that tied my
tongue so this is his initiation into
prayer
please lord stop these people from
beating me right he says
i prayed that i would not be beaten at
school
when you did not hear me
and it was not to be reputed following
me my punishments which were then a huge
and heavy evil to me were laughed at by
older men and even by my own parents who
wish no harm to befall me so you know
people see augustine praying and they're
like look at this stupid stupid little
kid you know god's not going to save him
from the the switch or the you know the
ruler or whatever it's going to be the
rod
augustine does tell us that he was not a
good student he says we sin by writing
reading and thinking over our lessons
less than was required of us there was
in us no lack of memory or intelligence
free will that we should have them in
sufficient measure for our years but
what did we want to do we wanted to play
we didn't want to buckle down and read
the these things and think about them
and he says no one has pity on either
children or grown-up men or on both
perhaps some fine judge of things
approves my beatings and you know he
asks
did the very man who beat me act
differently from me if he was outdone by
a fellow teacher in some trifling
discussion he was more tormented by
anger and envy than i was when beaten by
my classmates so these beatings are not
particularly
edifying and augustine tells us a little
bit later
this is in
uh
chapter
13 12 12 and 13 that he actually has to
be compelled to study and he tells us
that i did not love study i hated to be
driven to it but i was driven to it and
actually you know some good came out of
this it wasn't good that i was beaten
that's a bad thing but it was good that
i learned certain things because of it
because i wouldn't have been doing it he
says but it wasn't i didn't do good
myself i would have learned nothing
unless forced to it no one does good
against his will even if what he does
is good nor did those who drove me on do
well the good was done to me by you
god for setting things up and allowing
me to learn some some matters right
we find out that he
enjoyed learning latin and now we should
keep in mind too that augustine
latin was probably not his original
language although it was you know widely
spoken
he probably spoke some variety of punic
and then you know latin is spoken all
around uh in various parts but he has to
learn it because you know hearing a
language and actually understanding how
it works those are two different things
and then he's also supposed to learn
greek and he doesn't really
like to to read greek he says the first
stages of our education where we learn
reading writing and arithmetic i
considered no less a burden in
punishment than all the greek
courses
but you know he he
tries and then he says why did i hate
greek literature which you know sings of
all these sorts of things
and he says
we're forced to
learn these matters right and he's
beaten sadistically by his greek teacher
teachers and he doesn't really learn
greek because of that they they used
cruel punishments and threats
they in effect cut him off from an
opportunity to learn a foreign language
well a foreign language that would have
opened up to him you know entire
worlds of culture at the time
we can ask
what was augustine actually learning and
was it in fact good
now augustine says that the capacities
learning to read and write for example
learning arithmetic learning that was
good the way in which he learned it
getting beaten if he didn't make
progress not so good right but learning
to be able to
read language to write to compose to
articulate thoughts that is actually
quite helpful
when it comes to the ways in which it's
taught in terms of content augustine
says
not really great so you know if we if we
focus for example on chapter 16 he talks
about you know
we we studied these greek myths right
and those are not particularly good as a
matter of fact they're actually bad for
us because we're learning all sorts of
bad examples
for
a prime example
zeus screwing around on his wife
and you know we talk about how jove
reigns a golden shower into deny's lap
and thus tricks the girl you know we're
learning words we're learning words like
golden shower lap to see temples of
heaven and things like that and he says
in no way in no way whatsoever are these
words used here learned more easily
because of this filthy scene but because
of these words that vile deed is more
boldly perpetuated i'm not condemning
the words themselves but the wine of
error which through them was preferred
to us by drunken teachers unless
we took it in we were beaten and we had
no freedom of appeal so they are having
to read all these stories these you know
myths and legends and and plays and
poems about the greek gods and the awful
things that they're doing and they're
told this is what you you actually need
to take into your
mind and so you know that's a problem
augustine talks a little bit later about
having to give a speech in which here we
go
he says the task was assigned to me that
disturbed my mind
either by reason of the praise or
disgrace to be awarded or fear of a
flogging so he's already nervous about
this both because he doesn't want to get
beaten and because he he wants to do
well
i was to speak juno's words as she
expresses anger and sorrow because she
could not turn back the trojan king from
going to italy so this is from virgil's
aeneid right
i'd heard juno never spoke those words
yet we're compelled to wander off and
follow in the steps of these poetic
fictions and to put into prose with the
poet had spoken in verse
and you know he says what did this
matter to me god my true life what good
was for what good was i for my
declamation uh acclaimed above so many
of my schoolmates and boys
of the same age what was all this but
smoke and wind was there no other
subject on which to exercise my talents
and tongues i could have you know
used god's praises in in scriptures but
instead i'm
messing around with this stuff
from my you know contemporary
culture and so augustine thinks that's
that's not particularly good right and
this was part of the way in which
literature was taught
uh when we hear about grammar in the
ancient world grammar is not just
learning what we call grammar now it was
also reading literature and and
figuring out how to rearrange it to
compose
what about lessons about life
what really counts what's what counts as
success
here he gets the wrong lessons he says i
mean first of all the lesson that you
should beat students to motivate them
bad lesson right the fact that it's been
going on for generations doesn't make it
a good thing
um focusing in on the wrong
sorts of matters you know worldly
success
as he points out a little bit later
you know what they made me do is focus
on
speaking well
but here's a great
passage here he says
regard oh lord my god regard as is your
want how carefully the sons of men
observe the proprieties as to letters
and syllables received from former
speakers and how they neglect
everlasting covenants of eternal
salvation which they have received from
you so if a man who accepts or teaches
the ancient conventional forms of
pronunciation violates the rules of
grammar and utters the word homo which
is human being without sounding the h in
the first syllable he will offend men
more than if contrary to your laws
he who is a man himself would hate
another
person
it is as if he thought an enemy more
pernicious to him than his own hatred by
which he has aroused against another and
he says so what is augustine saying here
they have a mistaken sense of priority
about what they're focusing on what
they're teaching what they're compelling
students to learn and so they're getting
an education
that's halfway a miseducation
and is not really preparing them well
for their their life afterwards
and is probably damaging them
morally so this is augustine's account
of the
education that he received he's not
actually you know making any excuses for
himself he's not saying that he was
totally innocent he admits that he
didn't want to focus on his studies but
though the studies themselves and the
ways the means that were used to get
augustine to study are not particularly
productive
either and that is the fault of those
themselves miseducated adults
you